Uh, so far so good with, uh, medication, well, the side effects appear and worsen with time.
Um, they can. Yes.
Which I could say don't, but they can. Oh, I don't want to put something in your head
because maybe they won't want to. So, um, I do think when you decrease
four bones dramatically, the biggest change in symptoms comes immediately. But, um, over time,
you can have some deterioration of tissues like, um, like we discussed before, like hand,
like I think it's called the hand syndrome or something that comes with decreased in four
bones and, um, and, uh, some, uh, joint issues are really common with decreased in four bones.
Um, and that speaks to the question that we had earlier. Another thing that can be good for that
besides flavonoids and, and, and, anti-inflammatories can be dehydrated. Um, B6 can be helpful as well.
Uh, but I would treat it as symptoms appear. So good news. Um, happy for you there.